i very much enjoyed this i thought this
movie was so much fun
obviously there's some pressure on every
project because you want it to turn out
good you hope that it will but
what is the added pressure when you're
not only making a rom-com but you're
making a christmas rom-com i mean does
that feel like a lot to live up to
um no
i was really excited to be honest you
know it was uh it made it easier that
meshing with the cast was so easy um
jimmy and nina were both so welcoming
when i arrived i i came in late um
and we we got to you know really get get
um
be around each other a little bit before
we started shooting which i think really
bridged the gap in terms of breaking the
ice and provided that
warmth and and welcoming you know spirit
that christmas movies have
um
we just
i tried to live you know truthfully in
the script and and i think tried to
portray
you know the importance of uh
being yourself which is i think is a
huge theme
in the script and and movie and um
it was it was very easy it was just
being such a tight-knit family so
quickly um
gave us the that jolly spirit we needed
for uh you know providing that feeling
we know where each of these characters
fall in the debate of whether die hard
is really a christmas movie but what are
your thoughts on that is die hard a
christmas movie
i don't know i um
i don't remember that movie at all i
have not seen that movie since i was
very very young um
so i can't really uh be a part of that
debate as of yet i can get back to you
when i watch it but not now
well when you read the script were there
specific things about it about the
character that you were most excited
about were there things that you would
get to do that you were most looking
forward to what got you interested
yeah rock climbing was i was very
excited about that um
i am not the most avid nor skilled rock
climber on the planet but i love doing
it and so that was a lot of fun also the
bobsledding scene
um
i
in my head you know i was like oh great
they're going gonna have me in a real
bobsled
um
i won't explain what the what the case
is you know we can leave that for like
behind the scenes
um
but yeah it was it was a lot of fun and
also the writing just made me laugh very
early on and um being able to work with
jimmy and nina who both are so talented
and i was you know fans of their work
before i even met them i was excited for
all of it
the rock climbing scenes do seem like it
could be one of those situations where
it sounds really cool on paper when you
read it but once you're hanging out
there and doing multiple takes it could
turn into something you regret
so did you ever have a moment of like
why did i think this would be fun like
i'm hanging here for hours
you know
sure there there's times where you know
that thing the harness was riding up my
butt so much for hours and
my hands were beginning to hurt from
being held up there but at the end of
the day
you're sitting up there and you're like
i'm literally at work right now
you know it could be a lot worse i get
to hang here and have fun and be around
people i love and make art um as a job
and that's
something i think never to be taken for
granted and i need to have gratitude for
that all the time so
no no there was never a moment i was
like i hate my life right now i was just
like okay it's a little difficult but
hey
it's part of the job i've never heard
anybody say they love a harness so
yeah i don't love a harness but you know
if it's
art is pain you got to do what you got
to do
well with this movie and and even when
never have i ever the tone leans toward
comedy and you play the more serious
character would you like to play a
character that is more directly comedic
and get to do a bit more straight comedy
for something
um
yeah i'm always open to doing doing
straight comedy um i
i like playing more of the dry character
however i would also love to play
um a crazy zany character um
but i'm also really looking forward into
diving into you know deeper um darker
kind of more cinematic um experiences
and
i
produce and also start in a new movie
that we have in post-production right
now where i'm playing um
a character with schizophrenia as well
as um post-traumatic stress disorder
um so that has been a lot of fun
um
i'm very excited to show off that side
of myself um the movie's called
apophenia and we are no release date yet
we're imposed but um i'm excited for
that
was that something that you said you
were a producer on that i mean is that
something you sought out because you
wanted to
explore that kind of material
no uh my best friend uh one of my one of
my best friends wrote and
wrote and directed it and um
he said he wrote it for me because he
said i s he saw it in me that i
he was i saw the muscles inside you that
you wanted to flex and i i really kind
of catered it to you and i knew you were
one of the only people that could do
this based on conversations that we had
and um
yeah i think he hit the nail on the head
because um what's interesting with you
know drama and comedy i think is
the best comedy is when you don't think
you're being funny you know and i think
a lot of the best comedy is based in
drama
and so i think there's even parts of
this movie that you know
my my other movie apophenia where i'm
playing this darkness but it's almost
funny at points because it's you know
there's a reality in comedy yeah so you
know they're both fun
well it's definitely good to have a
friend who is looking out for you in
that way yeah thank god
well from everything that i read about
you it seems as though you had thoughts
of being an actor as a kid but it took
you a while to actually pursue it
what inspired the initial dream and then
what got you to actually finally get
serious about it
um jim carrey's outtakes from all of his
movies as well as just jim carrey in
general as a kid i was like
no one looks like they're having more
fun than this guy
um and i just fell in love that i'd go
around the house impersonating him
tirelessly for hours on end um
but you know
growing up
the dream of being an actor
i'll give an example i said i wanted to
be albert einstein and michael jordan at
the same time when i was five and my
parents were like yeah you can do
whatever you want like you can do
anything
and then i was like i want to be an
actor and they were like ah
well i don't know about that that's a
pretty tough road and i was like
okay i can be the most genius scientist
and the most
amazing athlete of all time at the same
time but acting is the unreal
unrealistic one
so i kind of put it on the back burner
you know my parents were never like you
can't do it they were just like you got
to be prepared to you know have a plan b
so i went to college um
at a place called barry college in rome
georgia of all places
and i got involved in the theater
uh company started doing plays i i got
involved in the student uh run media
organization started kind of making my
own content and i got bit by it all over
again so i graduated
i moved back to la and
started from scratch i was doing odd
jobs i was looking for acting work on
craigslist
that's a dark rabbit hole don't do that
um
but yeah i really just
um i realized that there was nothing
else
i really wanted to do
and i also wanted to do everything i
couldn't decide and i was acting as the
one place where
i don't have to decide i can be
a sports fanatic in a movie i can play a
lawyer i can play a doctor i can play
someone you know struggling with a
mental illness and it forces me to
really dive and research and i think you
know be able to live at least a little
bit of every single you know life and
it's limitless and that's why i just
could not stop
it seems like you went from doing guest
spots to recurring just series regular
and out of movies pretty quickly how is
that journey felt for you is it did you
have like any kind of plan did you have
this like goal for yourself or are you
surprised how your career has taken you
down these paths
um
you know it's
i'm i'm grateful more than anything
because i knew
when i was at my lowest at my
brokest at my most broken spiritedness
during this journey because it obviously
comes with a lot of rejection a lot of
no's
i realized i was not going to be able to
give it up i was like i would i there
were times where i did get a full-time
job and i kind of let it go and i was
like i am 20 times more miserable here
thinking about what if i was back doing
what i really love doing
so i'm just more grateful that i
had the strength and i had the you know
support system around me to convince me
not to stop
and um
yeah i mean sometimes it is surreal to
look and be like
you know i've i'm i've made this a
full-time thing
and
all i hope and pray every day is that it
keeps going that direction and i think
you know the way to do that is to stay
focused on
the moment at hand um operate with
gratitude and
you know really appreciate everyone
around you so that's what i'm kind of
focused on doing
tag is a character who's in a very
interesting position in this movie
because
he sort of finds himself in this
relationship with someone who he just
wants to share
things in common with and he doesn't
know his friend is
using his picture on a dating app he
doesn't know this girl knows that all of
this happened who do you think he feels
more betrayed by the guy pretending to
be him or the woman who knows what
happened but doesn't tell him about it
that's a good question
um i think he probably is a little bit
more
hurt
by his you know supposed childhood best
friend
um because not only did he use my photos
without my permission and
you know
trying to uh you know him poses me
he also was in on it with you know
natalie and
basically he was like willing to put my
heart on the line for a fake person so i
think at least in my in my um
personal opinion i would be a lot more
hurt by my friend
what did you enjoy about working with
nina because you're in some different
situations in this you know between the
rock climbing and and the bobsledding
where you get to do some fun
stuff was she just game for everything
what was it like to share scenes with
her
yeah yeah nina was really game for
everything and
you know we had a lot of scenes where
hernan kind of let us go off the rails
and ad-lib and do our thing and nina was
always a very i'd say like worthy
opponent i guess when it came to if i
gave an ad lib and you know sometimes
tried to stump her she came right back
and i think it made for some great
scenes and some of those ad-libs made
the cut um
which you know i guess even our director
and everyone else thought it worked out
so it was it was really great just it
was she was a great dance partner in in
scenes
what do you think happened to tag after
we leave him in the film do you think he
went off to find the right woman for him
or do you think he's just off having
more adventures
i think he's just off having more
adventures i think he
i think tag you know
i don't know got called
to some other country to go on some
crazy excursion and was like all right
and um he's i think he's he's going to
be just fine
what makes an enjoyable and entertaining
romantic comedy for you do you have like
a go-to romantic comedy it's like your
friends or or somebody wants to watch
one or you want to watch one
um
yeah i love
um
hitch
and i love crazy stupid love
i think those are two phones that
if they're on i'm just like i'm game to
watch them
[Music]
is it more of just like a lightning you
sort of like that lightness and the
humor that comes
with movies like that oh yeah yeah i
mean if it's if i just need to be kind
of put in a good mood or or find
hope again for for love regardless of
how sometimes unrealistic it can be
i don't think it hurts to kind of you
know fill your heart up with uh a little
bit of hope when you need it
which this movie has all those things i
i thought this movie was so much fun and
and really is kind of different and
unexpected in a lot of ways too which is
nice
yeah
well i definitely appreciate you talking
about it i'm and i'm excited to see the
other movie that we were talking about
as well so
thank you so much christine i appreciate
it thanks a lot
you